Harry: From exclusive
items to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the
differences between Ikea food
in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
Quick note: It turns
out Ikea does not offer
a takeout option, but
fortunately they do sell
lots of Tupperware containers.
So in case you're wondering why the food
looks a little bit sad,
it's because we had to
improvise. On with the video.
Let's start portion sizes
with Ikea's claim to fame
when it comes to food,
the Swedish meatballs.
In the US, Ikea's restaurant
offer only one portion size
for meatballs, eight pieces,
but after that you can get
them in increments of four.
For instance, 12 meatballs.
In the UK, Ikea's iconic meatballs
come in two portion sizes, eight or 12.
You can also add four extra
meatballs to any order
for an extra £1.75, and there's seemingly
no limit to how many
times you can do this.
In the UK, the meatballs come
with either mashed potatoes
or chips on the side, as
well as some garden peas,
lingonberry jam, and of
course their famous gravy.
And of course the meatball
options all come with a side
of mashed potatoes and
peas. Get a load of that.
Also a little bit of cranberry sauce.
We're going to weigh eight
meatballs in both countries
to see whose meatballs are bigger.
One, two,
three, four,
five, six,
seven, and eight.
Let's also try and weigh our mash.
Now, I do feel like the stats
might be skewed slightly
because there's some
peas embedded in this.
I will try and free it where I can.
We got way more mash than
the UK, like almost double!
They're feeding us at our Ikeas.
Vegans and vegetarians,
rejoice. Ikea also offers
vegetarian-vegan versions
of its meatballs right here.
We're doing a blind taste
test, plant versus meat.
That's definitely plant-based.
What's the next one?
Peter: No.
Oh, was that wrong?
Wait, OK, give me another one.
OK, this is the other one?
Yeah, that's meat. Not even close.
Not even close. Thank you, Peter.
Neither were bad.
And if I was a vegetarian or vegan,
I would be perfectly happy
with those plant balls.
Tasted perfectly fine, but
the difference is noticeable.
We share a couple of
dessert options with the US,
notably the Daim cake.
Over here, we call that
the caramel almond cake.
Let's weigh a slice.
Another dessert option
we share with the UK
is the soft-serve ice cream,
which you get in vanilla or strawberry.
OK, first of all, the
gentleman who worked there
was adamant that's actually frozen yogurt.
I don't know if that's true or not.
Regardless, they didn't have to-go cups
like Harry was able to get,
so all they would give us
is the small cup where
it's kind of poking out
like it's ready to eat.
It is 97 degrees in Los Angeles today.
There was absolutely no way
that was making it from Ikea
to the car, let alone the studio.
So here's footage of me enjoying
it in the lobby of Ikea.
So, I'm sorry I didn't bring the scale.
I don't know how much it weighs.
We have soft-serve ice
cream in the UK too,
either as vanilla or vanilla
with chocolate sauce.
Impressively, they've
given us exactly 100 grams
of soft-serve ice cream.
Ikea is also known for its hot dogs.
In the UK you can get
either a classic hot dog
or a veggie hot dog from the bistro stand.
We're going to measure and
weigh the classic hot dog
to compare with the US.
The hot dog in the UK
is 7 inches in length,
and with the toppings
of pickles and onions,
it weighs 114 grams.
Hot dog.
Our hot dog is 5 ¼ inches long,
and our hot dog weighs 75 grams.
Here are all the menu items from a UK Ikea
that you won't find in the US.
Here's all the food
you'll find in a US Ikea
you won't find in the UK.
Starting out down here, hot entrées.
This single piece of chicken
is the Havana chicken.
Now, it doesn't come alone.
It comes with plantains,
rice, and beans, which we
will see in a little bit.
But just isolated, the chicken,
has been sitting for a minute, sorry.
Havana chicken. I wonder
what makes it so Havana.
Yeah, I'm definitely
getting some spices in here.
Very flavorful, not just, like,
a standard piece of chicken.
It's actually really good.
We'll start down this end
with some main courses.
We have two different
nonmeat-meatball options in the UK.
Firstly, we have the veggie balls.
These are meatballs which are formed
of ground-up vegetables,
and they're also served with
a vegetable couscous as well.
But for vegetarians who
prefer something a bit more
reminiscent of meat, they
also have plant balls.
Now, I'm kind of intrigued by these
because they look really good.
These are a fake-meat version
of Ikea's classic meatballs.
Now, compared to a classic meatball,
they're actually almost
more visually appealing,
I would say. They're a nice,
dark, golden brown color.
They look like they've been
cooked in a similar way,
maybe even kind of fried
or cooked for longer than
you would expect from these.
Let's do a very quick taste
test. Classic meatball.
We all know and love it.
These things are delicious.
And then one of the plant balls.
I will say the plant-based
one doesn't have that
distinct Ikea meatball taste to it.
That said, still pretty tasty.
I think texture-wise,
it's almost identical
to the classic meatball.
You can also get a salmon
filet with pea pesto,
vegetable medallions, and a corn medley,
which you can see right here.
I mean, salmon's OK, I guess.
OK. This isn't, it's
been sitting for a while.
If you like salmon, sure.
I don't know, you go to
Ikea, you get salmon?
Pea pesto's interesting though.
Still in the mood for fish
before you go furniture shopping?
You can also get the garlic
lemon cod with, of course,
mashed potatoes and peas.
Actually, that's a pretty
good piece of fish.
Yeah, I actually really like that.
OK, I stand corrected.
I was dissing the fish.
It's actually pretty good.
We have a British classic dish,
and that's fish and chips.
Now, the fish they serve at
Ikea in the UK is pollack.
It comes with chips, peas,
and some tartar sauce.
Now, unlike fish and
chips that you might find
from a classic chippy in the UK,
they've actually breaded their fish
rather than battered and then fried it.
I generally prefer the
battered fish texture.
I like the kind of crispy
crunch on the outside
that you get from batter.
I'm going to have a little try of this.
It's very weird tasting
things on "Food Wars"
using a knife and fork. I don't like it.
I respect that they have
attempted to localize their menu
to the UK market.
But maybe put a bit more
thought into your R&D there.
If you want to see what proper
fish and chips looks like,
go and check out our "Food Tours"
best fish and chips in London video.
Next up we have another fish
option. It's a salmon filet.
Charlie: Fillet.
Leon: Come on.
Next up we have another fish
option. It's a salmon fillet.
In the UK, we generally
lean more towards "fillet"
as the wording, and also we
spell it slightly differently.
Often we spell it with two L's,
whereas I believe in the US
it tends to be spelled with one.
I think you can get a
salmon fillet in the US.
However, like we say,
we pronounce ours slightly differently,
and also in the UK ours comes
with the veggie couscous.
Chicken tenders. I mean, come on.
Comes with fries and broccoli.
Hm, wait, these tenders
are actually very good.
Like, the breading,
they're really breaded.
Decent fries. Hearty.
Ikea also has a few things on the menu
that were not available
at the one we went to.
A chicken thigh with
garlic chipotle sauce,
broccoli, and rice. Sounds
actually pretty good.
Lingonberry barbecue
ribs with mac 'n' cheese.
Ah! I was so mad they didn't have those.
And a plant-based burger with fries,
also not available at
time of filming this.
Now, lingonberries are majorly
popular in Swedish cuisine,
and you're going to see
them pop up a few more times
in the Ikea menu.
Next up is penne pasta with tomato sauce.
Penne, of course, refers
to the shape of pasta
that they use here in Ikea.
[Charlie laughing]
Charlie's loved that.
I think penne is maybe my
least favorite pasta shape.
I do not respect penne.
Moving swiftly on from the penne,
we have a chicken katsu curry.
I think this is a relatively new addition
to the UK Ikea menu.
So, katsu refers to the
chicken katsu fillet,
which is a breaded and
fried piece of chicken,
and then it's served with
rice and katsu sauce.
I've not tried this before.
That looks like one just massive
piece of chicken, you know?
Science.
Other than a couple of
slightly disconcerting
dark patches inside the chicken breast,
it's actually not bad. I
think because of the size
of the breast it's dried out quite a lot,
but the katsu sauce is really nice.
I like it with the rice.
I think particularly
if we'd eaten this hot,
this actually would be pretty good.
Next up on the UK menu you can find
a potato and cauliflower rogan josh curry.
A rogan josh is a curry
that you'll find on the menu
of a lot of UK curry houses.
It's not super spicy,
generally quite mild.
I'd say traditionally you
would see this made with lamb,
but they've made a
vegetarian version here,
obviously with potato and cauliflower
as the main bulk of it.
The rogan josh from Ikea
is served with rice,
and then you can also
get some side options
which are designed to go with
it, including some pakoras,
samosas, and a garlic naan.
Obviously the UK has a large
British Indian population,
so I do think this is another attempt to
kind of localize the menu.
That's pretty good.
That's pretty flavorful.
There are some other main-course
options from UK Ikeas
which unfortunately we
couldn't find today.
These include such things
as butternut squash
and sweet potato soup;
Mangalore chicken curry;
butternut squash, blue cheese,
and caramelized onion pie;
chili sin carne; garlic
butter chicken pie;
and leek and potato soup.
I would like to move on to the sides.
Right here we have the
vegetable medallions.
I like veggies presented like this,
just like in a little
puck. Just bite into it.
Looks like it has some broccoli,
mostly potato friendly, little onion.
Yeah, not bad. Decent side.
It's like broccoli potatoes,
like broccoli mashed potatoes.
That Havana chicken that
I mentioned earlier,
this is the beans and rice it comes with.
I don't know if they mix them
up or it just got mixed up
in transit, but, you know,
beans and rice. Let's go.
This is just white rice and black beans.
I don't taste any additional
flavor to this at all.
They do sometimes offer plantains.
Again, the Ikea we went to
today did not have plantains,
but they did have a garlic bread.
I think that's an exclusive.
On to the Ikea cold dishes.
They have a veggie dog.
Well, the veggie dog wrap
is under the cold dishes
according to the script,
and this veggie dog is cold.
Maybe it's been sitting a while.
Either way, it's not very good.
Also, they have a Greek
salad, also the Caesar salad,
which, once again, I mean,
this is pretty low effort.
A Stockholm salad,
not to be confused with
Stockholm syndrome,
which I'm starting to feel
right now eating this food.
Salmon, lettuce, lemon.
Sure.
That's not bad, actually.
I like this sauce that's
turning color under these lights
and this salmon.
We're not quite sure
what is in this salad,
what the sauce is right now,
but due the miracle of editing,
we can put that on the screen right,
and that's what it is.
Tastes pretty good.
Also, you can get a BLT chicken wrap.
Not bad if you like wraps
and BLT and chicken.
Also at a US Ikea, which was not available
at time of filming this
at our Burbank Ikea,
is a Greek veggie ball
wrap and marinated salmon.
The UK's cold-plate menu is
pretty bland in comparison.
The only one they had today was
this marinated salmon plate,
but we can also get an egg
and shrimp sandwich with mayo,
marinated salmon wrap, small salad bowl,
and a tomato and mozzarella salad.
I guess I'll give the salmon a quick try.
I do like smoked salmon.
Here, of course, they call it gravlax
because it's the traditional Swedish way,
and it comes with a dill
sauce and some lemon.
Fairly mild flavor.
I like the kind of herb
crusting that you get.
The dill sauce is pretty dilly.
And now on to desserts.
There are three exclusive
Ikea US desserts.
I was only able to get one of them.
So, the first would be
the strawberry shortcake,
not available at time of shooting this.
The second is this, the
caramel almond cake.
And the third is the infamous
chocolate layered cake,
also known as the conspiracy cake.
I asked everyone there,
"Please tell me you have chocolate cake."
And they all said no.
No chocolate cake at the
Burbank Ikea, today, at least.
Tragically, we don't
have the conspiracy cake
here in the UK, but we do have some other
exclusive dessert options.
For example, this
delightful-looking strawberry tart.
There's some real pieces
of strawberry in there.
I like the pastry, I like the cream,
I like the fresh strawberries.
Whatever the kind of
strawberry syrup jelly stuff
that they've put around
the outside is, it's OK,
but it has a slightly, almost
medicinal quality to it
that I don't really love. It
almost reminds me of Calpol.
I don't know if you have that in the US,
but it's a medicine
that's marketed towards
children in the UK.
Next up, we have Ikea's famous Daim cake.
Now, you do have this on
the menu in the US, however,
I believe you guys call it
something slightly different.
I think caramel almond cake.
Is Daim not a particularly
big brand name in the US?
Because over here in the
UK I'd say most people
are familiar with Daim
as a chocolate brand.
Harry was just talking a
minute ago about the Daim cake,
the diam cake, D-I-A-M cake?
I've never heard of it. I've
never heard of that brand.
I have no idea what it is, I'm
sorry, but we do have this,
which I think is supposed to be similar.
Oh, yeah. This is fantastic.
I'm getting one of these every time I go.
I'm going to get one of these,
and I'm going to get that
chocolate cake. I'm going to
be on the lookout for it now.
It's maybe not quite as popular
in the UK as it used to be.
It reminds me of my grandad a lot
because he used to really love a Daim bar.
I wouldn't see many people
my age going for it,
but still very tasty if
you're in the mood for it.
And this cake is sensational.
You get these layers of chocolate,
this kind of biscuity crumb,
and these kind of, like,
almost pancakes in the middle.
I think these dividing
lines might almost be
kind of cold, chilled pancakes.
This might be my favorite
thing on the menu.
This is why I'm making
excuses to go to Ikea.
Mm.
They did have these at the register,
and this also says Daim
on it. Have we seen that?
Yeah. OK, this tastes like this.
Never heard of this, but it's very good,
and this is fantastic.
Maybe they just rebranded
it because no one in the US
knows what ... Daim cake? Diam cake is?
Our next dessert option is a cheesecake
with blueberries and raspberries.
It's a very soft cheesecake,
really easy to cut.
There's a nice baked crumb on top.
There's a layer of the berry stuff,
so there's some blueberries
in there, some raspberries.
Then finally we have these
Under the Sea rocky road biscuits.
Obviously, rocky road
in the UK is a dessert,
which is usually a no-bake
dessert made of things
like melted chocolate,
golden syrup, marshmallows,
even things like cornflakes,
pieces of biscuit,
that sort of thing, all
just kind of mixed together,
left to set, and then you
have a nice easy dessert.
It turns out what makes this Under the Sea
is that they have a kind of animal stamp
in icing on top of it. Here
we have this nice octopus,
and here we have a couple of dolphins.
I think when I eat a rocky road
I kind of want some
more distinct elements.
I like being able to bite
into it and crunch through
a bit of biscuit or chew
through a raisin or something.
Whereas with this one, it's
kind of all blended together,
so you don't really get
the texture contrasts.
The flavor's very much there.
It's still all those elements
that I'm used to in terms of the flavor.
You may also be able to find
some other dessert options
on a UK menu which we couldn't find today.
These include things like a
caramelized biscuit cheesecake,
a chocolate clementine bomb,
an elderflower and lemon cake,
a gooey chocolatey cake,
a lemon cheesecake,
rhubarb and custard cake,
and a strawberry jelly.
Aside from its restaurant, Ikea also has
the Swedish bistro for quick bites.
The bistro serves quick bites
like hot dogs and pizza slices
that you can generally grab
on your way out of the store.
A few exclusives we had,
of course, was pizza slice.
There it is.
I went with cheese.
Is this like Costco where, like, surprise,
Ikea has amazing pizza?
This is a really good slice of pizza.
I can't tell, but I think
this was oven-cooked,
fire-oven-cooked, not
just like the pizza oven.
This has, like, a,
yeah, like a brick oven.
It's not as good as Costco,
but it's pretty good.
Wow, weird. Ikea's got good
pizza. Good on you, Ikea.
You can also get this
giant bistro pretzel.
Look at this little,
like, a little braid here.
Look at me, I'm a Jedi.
But you are not a Jedi yet.
And it comes with mustard.
They didn't have the mustard either, man.
I don't know, is it because I
went at 10:30 in the morning
and the stuff hadn't shown up yet?
They didn't have anything.
A pretzel with no mustard.
No, no.
You need to dip in something.
Also at the US Ikea bistro,
you can get a marinated salmon baguette.
They didn't have it.
We have a few exclusive bistro
options of our own in the UK.
Firstly, if you like the
onions on the hot dog,
you can just get a side of fried onions.
Next up we have these,
which are chick'less strips.
So, these are a plant-based
version of a chicken tender.
I'd say they look pretty good.
They kind of passed the visual test.
Yeah, when I tore this apart I was worried
that the texture wasn't going to be right,
and unfortunately it's not.
It's very spongy, it's very mushy.
It just needs a little bit more texture.
Just something to make it resemble
a chicken tender a little bit more.
Obviously when you get an
actual piece of chicken tender
or chicken breast, you
can kind of tear it,
and you see those strips and the fibers.
They just really haven't got that here.
Flavor's not too bad, though.
We can also get chips
from the bistro in the UK.
It doesn't seem like you
guys can do this in the US.
We have our veggie dog option,
which comes with the same
toppings as the regular hot dog.
So, here we've got fried onions.
You can also get some with pickles.
The veggie dog in the UK isn't
a plant-based-meat thing,
it is just vegetables.
So it looks like there's some
kale in there, some carrot,
maybe, like, some mustard seeds.
I think that, with the fried onions,
with the pickles and some sauce,
actually a pretty good veggie option.
Then we have some drink
options, notably milkshakes.
In the UK you can get
milkshakes in four flavors,
vanilla, chocolate,
strawberry, and banana.
We got a banana one
today. Have a little sip.
That's not bad. Pretty
gentle banana flavor.
It's mostly just ice cream
but with a little bit
of flavoring in that,
which, who could say no?
Ikea in the UK does serve
breakfast, although unfortunately
when we arrived today
they weren't serving it.
The options that you'll
find there are pretty much
everything that you would normally find
on a full English breakfast,
so it includes things like
bacon, sausages, hash browns,
beans, tomatoes, mushrooms, black pudding.
Sometimes you'll find things
like tattie scones as well,
and you can also get
white or wholemeal toast.
If breakfast platters aren't your thing,
then you can also just go for
some fruit or some porridge.
Breakfast!
The breakfast platter in the
US also comes in both regular
and small sizes and is made
up of eggs, potatoes, bacon,
Swedish pancakes, and now
it's supposed to be topped
with the lingonberry jam, and
they didn't give it to us!
The US breakfast menu also offers
a skagen croissant sandwich,
which is a croissant
filled with traditional
Swedish shrimp salad.
They didn't have it.
I think Ikea has its own
line of drinks available
in its restaurants. The US
Ikeas, you'll find cola,
sugar-free cola,
sparkling raspberry juice,
lingonberry juice, and sparkling lemonade.
I went ahead and got
the lingonberry juice.
Straight up, no idea
what a lingonberry is,
but it's fantastic.
There's no difference in the size cups.
You just have glasses
that are the same size
or these to-go cups or whatever.
We have some drink options
at the restaurant in the UK
that you guys might not have in the US.
There are a couple of options for kids,
which are these Pip Organic juices.
We have a couple of
Robinsons options in the UK.
Robinsons is probably the
most popular brand of squash
in the UK, and this is basically just
a diluted version of their squash.
Squash, for those who don't
know, is a concentrated,
fruity drink that you kind of water down
to have a nice refreshing beverage.
You can get a peach and mango version
or a raspberry and apple version.
And if you feel like celebrating
any of your purchases
that you've just made
from the Ikea, you can also get alcohol.
We have three alcoholic options
on the menu at a UK Ikea,
a rosé wine, a red wine, or a dark lager.
Finally, Ikea has a Swedish
market where you can buy
prepackaged food items to take home.
The items on offer include
some of their classic foods,
like the meatballs,
which you can buy frozen,
or some gravy sachets,
which you can make at home.
In the UK, you can also
find the plant-based balls
on offer in there.
You can get a whole frozen Daim cake,
which I'll be taking home
and eating all by myself.
And speaking of Daim, you
can also get the chocolate
which the cake is based on.
Here it's in bite-sized form rather than
as actual chocolate
bars, but as you can see,
it's chocolate with a kind
of hard caramel center.
Charlie has dibs on these.
Another thing at the US Ikea,
maybe not exclusives per se,
but of course they have a
whole thing of frozen stuff.
I just grabbed stuff that was interesting.
Come on, the Cinnabons, huh?
The cinnamon buns.
Meatballs.
And, you know we were talking about
the Daim cake,
but they do have, it's
frozen to take home,
and of course it is the Daim cake.
Let's compare the nutritional
information of some iconic
Ikea dishes in the US and the UK.
In the UK, eight Ikea meatballs
contains the following:
342 calories,
25.1 grams of fat,
8.2 grams of carbs,
and 856 milligrams of sodium.
In the US, the same plate
of Swedish meatballs contain
304 calories,
22.4 grams of fat,
6.4 grams of carbs,
592 milligrams of sodium.
The UK takes this round in every category.
What about the Ikea hot dog?
In the US it contains 260
calories, 15 grams of fat,
24 grams of carbs, and
780 milligrams of sodium.
And in the UK, the hot
dog contains 293 calories,
15.2 grams of fat, 29.5 grams of carbs,
and 708 milligrams of sodium.
Looks like the UK version
is higher in calories
and fat once again. USA, baby.
What's actually in the
iconic Ikea meatballs?
According to the Ikea
website, if you want to make
their meatballs at home, use
the following ingredients:
beef mince, pork mince, onion,
garlic, bread crumbs, milk,
egg, and salt and pepper to taste.
But is that actually the ingredients list
for proper Ikea meatballs?
Well, on the back of the frozen packet,
you'll find an ingredients list.
According to this packet, they
contain beef, pork, water,
bread crumbs, egg, dried onion,
salt, egg powder,
black pepper extract, and allspice.
Overall, it seems like it's
pretty close to the list
that they gave you on the
website, with a few more things
like powdered ingredients
versus fresh ingredients,
and a couple of spice differences too.
I wasn't able to find it online
or in the cafeteria,
the ingredients list, but I got here
the frozen precooked meatballs,
and those ingredients ...
hm, actually not bad.
Assuming these are the ones
that they have in the cafeteria
in the US, the ingredients
for this is beef, pork,
water, bread crumbs made
of unbleached wheat flour,
salt, and yeast,
whole eggs, salt,
dehydrated onion, egg white,
that's not plural. Egg white, singular.
Spices.
That's not bad, I think, for
a prepackaged product, right?
It's like, well, that's, you
know, what's in them, right?
While we're on the subject
of Ikea ingredients,
one thing that UK viewers might remember
was our infamous horsemeat scandal.
Back in 2013, a number of foods
in the UK claiming to be beef or pork
were actually found to
contain traces of horsemeat.
While this wasn't
necessarily a health issue,
it did raise some major
questions concerning
the traceability of foods
throughout supply chains,
and unfortunately Ikea was
also caught up in this scandal.
Czech authorities found
traces of horsemeat
in some Ikea meatballs that
had been produced in Sweden
and shipped all around Europe.
Thankfully, the horsemeat
meatballs were found
before they reached consumers.
In total, 760 kilograms of
meatballs were destroyed.
Given the fact that
there's no health concerns
related to the consumption of horsemeat,
I think they should have
just leaned into it.
Just passed them off as, like,
limited-edition horse meatballs,
and just go with it, lads, it's fine.
Ikea's food is almost suspiciously cheap,
and it's actually one of
the ways it tricks you into
spending more time and
money in its stores.
Ikea is basically willing
to take its losses
with its cheap food prices
because it's counting on you
to spend a bunch of money
on furniture and other household items.
A former Ikea executive even
referred to the meatballs
as the "best sofa seller."
In the UK, a plate of
eight meatballs, peas,
mash or chips, gravy, and lingonberry jam
will set you back just £4.95.
At the time of recording,
that's around $6.49.
I do have to say, that's really cheap.
I don't think the quality's that bad.
It's really tasty food and,
yeah, it's a real bargain.
I will make an effort
to go via the restaurant
if I'm just going through Ikea.
Even if I'm just popping in
for, like, one or two bits,
I'm going to sit down,
eat a plate of meatballs.
It's good value, it's tasty, I love it.
An eight-meatball meal in the US is $9.99,
which in the UK is £7.80.
That's a 54% increase in the States.
Overall I would say Ikea is
pretty popular in the UK.
It's most people's go-to
for basic furniture
and household needs, I would say,
especially when people are buying a house
or moving house or something like that.
Personally, I love Ikea.
I love going there.
I do enjoy a trip. It's
fun. I like the food.
I like walking around
and pretending, like,
"Ooh, that could be my apartment
or my bedroom or my kitchen."
I wouldn't say Ikea is
somewhere I go often,
particularly because I live
in quite central London,
and there aren't many in Central London.
I think they're trying to
open one on Oxford Street
right now. At the time of
recording this, it wasn't open,
but they're kind of trying to get there.
But so, like I say, it's more
of a place where you'll go
specifically when you
need to do an Ikea shop.
Ikea is so popular here.
I think it's popular in the whole country.
The one in Burbank, we went
there at 10:30 in the morning.
It opens at 10, and at 10:30,
parking lot was pretty full.
The cafeteria line was full.
So I'd say Ikea's pretty popular.
I personally wouldn't go
to Ikea just for the food.
Again, it might be because
I don't live close enough
to one to make that worthwhile.
I do love the food. The
meatballs are great.
Like I say, the desserts are fantastic.
But I don't like it to
the extent that I would
make the effort to travel
to one just to eat there.
I'm not going to say I
go to Ikea for the food,
but the food definitely is a
good motivator to go to Ikea.
I will say overall I
do enjoy the experience
of going to an Ikea.
I am aware that it's kind of designed
to make us spend money.
Obviously the restaurant
plays a part of this as well,
because it's kind of
encouraging you to make a day
of your trip to Ikea, really
spend some time there,
sit down, take a break in
the middle of the day, eat,
re-energize yourself for more shopping.
And as you can guess by
my friends on the table
with me here, I do think that
their marketing is a really
clever ploy to make us spend
more money there as well.
I'm joined here by my friend Djungelskog.
I'm really sorry, I'm going to
butcher these pronunciations.
And my friend Blåhaj, who
is the adorable little shark
who is also, I think, a
trans icon. Love that.
You'll often see things like this
really getting a
reputation on the internet,
driving more commerce to Ikea stores.
I don't know if they're
doing that deliberately
or if it's just kind of a
side effect of making some
very, very cute plush toys.
But everyone, I think, will generally have
at least one thing from
Ikea in their home.
So whatever they're doing,
it's kind of working.
I'm not mad about it either.
I support Ikea. Keep
up the good work, guys.